My name is Auggie Pullman.
Next week, I start 5th grade.
And since I've never been to a real school before, I'm pretty much totally petrified.
I'll see you later.
You don't want to walk up with your parents because it's not cool.
But you're cool.
I know I am but technically, most dads aren't and neither are these helmets.
Dear God, please make them be nice to him.
Hi!
You don't have to do this.
I don't know what you're talking about, Auggie.
You don't have to pretend is all I'm saying.
Auggie!
Okay, I'm really sorry.
Why are you sitting here then?
Because I want some nice friends for a change.
Me too.
Who is it that I aspire to be?
That is the question that we should be asking ourselves all the time.
Hey Jack, come sit here.
In a sec.
You haven't thought about having plastic surgery?
Dude,  this is after plastic surgery.
It takes a lot of work to look this good.